يعني عمليات الانقاذ مستمره ومتواصله وان
كانت قد شاهدت بالنوع من التباطؤ خاصه في
شمال غرب البلاد والساحل والداخل من قبل
انقاذ بسبب الاعياء الشديد والليل ويعني
فقدان الامل بالعثور على احياء لكن استطيع
ان اؤكد لك انه خلال 22 ساعه
حتى الان يعني 220 ساعه حتى الان لم يتم
العثور على اي احياء في جميع المواقع التي
تقوم فيها فرق البحث والانقاذ
يعني بهدف الوصول الى اين جين ايضا لم
تصدر من المباني المدمره اي اصوات لبشر
عالقين تحت هذه الانقاب مما يعني يعطي
مؤشرات بان يعني فرص العثور على احياء
قضاءلت ولربما
انعدمت ولكن عمليات انتشال الركام ما زالت
قائمه صحيح حتى وان كانوا سيجدون الجثث
تحت هذه الانقاض
صحيح في حماه مثلا الاعمال انتهت منذ
يومين في حلب يعني مركز المدينه لعمان
تشارف على الانتهاء مع وصول الفرق البحث
والانقاذ الى 53 منزل من اصل اربعه 53
مبنى من اصل 54 مبدا يعني هناك مبنى واحد
بقي في مركز مدينه حلب تقوم الفرق بازاله
الانقاض عنه وبالتالي ستنتهي يعني خلال
اليوم او خلال ساعات الاعمال في حلب لكن
في ارياف ادلب وارياف حلب العمل لا يزال
مستمر بشكل واسع خاصه في الاتارب وسرمده
وسلقين والانظار كلها والجهود كلها متركزه
على جنديرس التي تشهد يعني اكبر نسبه دمار
للمباني على مستوى سوريا وايضا من حيث
الوفيات هناك 84 مبنى سكني مهدم
اكثر من 150 مبنى تجاري وصناعي ايضا مهدم
اكثر من الف مبنى مت صدع فيه وفيه وفيه
شقوق من ال 84 مبنى الذي يتوقع انه يكون
تحته عائلات فرق الانقاذ وصلت يعني الى 34
مبنى لا يزال هناك 50 مبنى يجب على فرق
الانقاذ والبحث ان تشمل عملياتهم هذه
المباني الذي اتوقع ان يكون تحتها العشرات
من الجثث لان لا اصوات ولا نداءات تسمع من
تحت هذه المباني